zach is in charlotte hey zach welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hey dave how you guys doing better than
we deserve man what's up in your world
uh i i need a little bit of help uh i'm
trying to figure out how to set some
boundaries with my roommates who are
very irresponsible with money
and i know that conventionally you'd
probably tell me just to leave
but the other issue i have is my wife
does not
will not allow it at the moment i'm
trying to deal with that with marriage
counseling but until i can get that
solved i need to figure out how to set
the boundaries so that i
don't have to keep cleaning up life will
not allow
you to leave your
your responsible roommates is that what
you just said
yeah yeah okay so understood walk me
through
wife plus roommates yeah that's to start
with i'm already confused
uh uh the female roommate is her best
friend
of since they were kids uh we live with
her and her
husband and because of that particular
relationship dynamics she does not want
to leave the same household i'm fine
with staying the same vicinity i love
these people
but while we live in the same house they
keep making irresponsible decisions with
money
i keep having to clean up the mess and
i'm getting sick and tired of coming
to end up living with them is this like
a like a commune do you all have sheep
and like chickens what are you all doing
was uh what happened was
uh so what had happened
yeah pretty much um no this is pretty
dave back in the end of like 2018 start
of 2019 my wife and i almost separated
because of marital issues
okay that's a surprise but uh
and you guys thought hey i know i know
what i can do i know what can help
we got to get roommates no you she moved
in
did you move in with him or did she
moved in with them
uh kind of both what happened was after
after the separation when we got back
together and decided we were going to
try to work things out
her friend invited me why don't we try
moving out to north carolina with them
we were living in colorado at the time
of the separation
the town we lived in had a lot of toxic
people that was part of the issue
and her friend was going to try to get
her into some
good counselors that would help her out
because the counselors in our area are
not very good and uh
we moved out there and then due to
financial stress
pre-dave and then the pandemic
and stuff we weren't able to get our own
place or
better the situation and it kind of
evolves to where she just doesn't want
to leave at
all she wants if she had her way she
wants to live with these people for the
rest of their lives like we get a house
together stuff like that but
their irresponsibility that's not gonna
work so zach
you're your marriage is in trouble and
you know that right
oh yes i know that okay so i don't like
because i'm happy about it i'm not happy
that's right that's right
so do you have there's two separate
things here one is to answer your
question do you have legal
responsibilities to clean the mess up of
these roommates
meaning did you sign the lease and
they're just okay then
to set up the boundaries there stop
spending your money to clean up their
financial messes
okay i wish there was a more complex way
to do that but you need to sit down and
say
from this point forward i'm not bailing
out the home
for your part of fill in the blank bill
um uh rent et cetera what is the
financial arrangement
um for you to live there you pay
normally
apparently it's just we go 50 50 on the
rent and the bills and stuff issues
right now
one of uh the husband of the other
couple
he is currently unemployed and we're
waiting to get a new social security
card so that he can get a new job
somebody stole his wallet a few months
ago and
then he got fired we've been trying to
replace it but it's just
taking forever because of the virus
well okay i say we because i did shell
out a few bucks to help him i still have
some money to help him get his birth
certificate so that he can get it
and that's what we're waiting on so we
can get the so what are you what what is
your income
uh like what do i do for a living or
what do you make a year
uh roughly 38k what about your wife does
she work
i know she doesn't work you have
children
none that are she's got a daughter but
she's not in our custody
okay so why does she not work
uh she's got really bad social anxiety
and back problems
and
i feel that saying this i'm not sure if
it's a matter she can't or she won't
okay that's fine i'm trying to get her
into counseling
yeah so
dave feel free to bop me upside the head
here at this point
zack i'm gonna let my wife know in 30
days i'm going to move out
it's not a helpful it's not a safe place
for your relationship
um it's not a good financial arrangement
you're running a household of four on a
38 thousand dollar income
and your marriage is deteriorating
underneath you and she's told you point
blank
i'm not leaving and so
in a way she is separating from you by
staying put
and at some point you've got to take
care of what you can take care of which
is you
and i would i mean dave you can feel
free to say but
i'd get a one bedroom apartment and say
this is where i'm gonna move
and i hope you will join me here this is
where my money's gonna be
this is where our care is gonna be and
then at some point you
have to stop blaming every quote-unquote
mental health professional
in your area and that means they're
probably telling you guys some stuff
y'all didn't feel like hearing
but you're gonna have to go get some
some help on your own whether it's from
a good pastor or
from a counselor in your area and you
gotta start working on you man
but at some point the fantasy of this
thing's just gonna roll back out and
it's all gonna be good
your wife's choosing to live with her
friend and his husband
or her husband over you and that's just
the reality of it and at some point
you've gotta
kill that fantasy and start living in
the reality of you're gonna have to make
some plans and decisions yeah you need
to sit down with a marriage counselor to
guide you through
how to um phrase this in a way that is
is hopefully healing and hopefully would
lead her to go with you
uh but you need to leave yeah because
let me just tell you let me tell you
what i heard okay
my wife would live with these people the
rest of our lives
i heard you say that now that's either
drum overdramatization hyperbole
or just weird yeah just straight up
strange so something's gotta give you or
she's done with you yeah and she's not
gonna make that that may be the message
right that may be the message
and i don't know you've got two two guys
in this country more high on marriage
than
dave ramsey we both are high high on
marriage
but this is a situation that you've
you've got to start protecting yourself
and she's got it y'all got to get out of
that situation